one of the busiest men in the country
joining us now the health secretary
sergeant javid hello thanks for joining
good morning
we really appreciate you taking thank
you for having me how many people a day
do you want to vaccinate how do they go
about getting the jab and will the
centers be open through christmas
well thank you again for having me the
since we learned about omicron our
strategy has been to to buy time to
assess it and to build our defenses what
we now know about omicron is that first
of all that it's spreading at a
phenomenal rate something that we've
never seen before it's doubling every
two to three days in infections and that
means we're facing a tidal wave of
infection is we're once again in a race
between the vaccine and the virus the
second thing that we now know for sure
is that the vaccines two doses are not
enough but three doses still provide
excellent protection against symptomatic
infection and that's why the booster
program has become more important than
ever we've boosted more people than any
other country in europe already but we
now need to go on a new national mission
and that's what we're doing that's what
the prime minister announced yesterday
we are extending and opening the booster
program to all over 18 starting from
today in walk-in centers they can book
for wednesday to give them all a chance
to get their booster shot before the new
year and the way we're going to do this
is by expanding it to a level the
booster program that we've never seen
before in terms of vaccination in this
country so we're going to have even more
vaccination centers we're going to open
all vaccination centers seven days a
week for at least 12 hours a day some
for many many longer than that somewhere
even perhaps 24 hours um over over the
christmas holiday period uh they'll be
open every day
i i'm not sure
i don't think they're going to open on
christmas day at this point
they'll be open the current planning is
to open them every other day
well let me tell you how we're going to
do it well that's how many you'll need
we'll have to look the target is huge of
course it's a huge target the highest
well the highest we've ever achieved
before with the vaccination program is
around 770 000 in a day yeah in just in
terms of vaccinations
with boosters with seven uk we've
achieved 770 000 before that's the
highest in a single day in england
before and so to
to try to boost this many people you're
going to have to even beat that every
single day now that is that is you're
it's a look it's a phenomenal
target in the final thing we want to do
but it will only work if of course we've
got the capacity there and that's why
we're building this capacity including
different types of units mobile units
and pop-up units asking gps to do more
and pharmacists to do even more we've
brought in 41 military planners covering
every region in england to help with the
logistics and the planning working with
the the with all the fantastic people
we're putting we are throwing everything
at it and can i just please say this to
your viewers
please play your part this could not be
more important we need to win this race
against the growth of this virus as i
say we've never seen this kind of growth
before so please do come forward protect
yourselves your loved ones and your
community is it because astrazeneca
wasn't as good as we initially thought
and actually the booster either pfizer
or moderna is what's helping no it's i i
think that would be completely unfair
astrazeneca has played a phenomenal role
in protecting that's the accuracy so
you're saying it's a
remember the first countries in the in
the world to start vaccinating uh that
has meant that we have slowly started we
saw this over especially over the summer
we started opening up we are still one
of the most open countries and because
of the success of our vaccination
program and astrazeneca has played a
phenomenal role what we the difference
now is is this variant and different
types of vaccines will react in
different ways but whether it's
astrazeneca you had for your first two
doses or spies or
you still need a booster shot to be
protected against this new variant how
many people are in hospital with omicron
this morning
it's it's around 3 000 confirmed cases
uh in england
i'm sorry i beg your pardon i
misunderstood your question um cases is
around 3000.
they're in in england's about 10 people
that are confirmed in england with
omicron
how many are on ventilators
i'm i'm i don't have the answer to that
question i don't know how ill they are
in hospital how many have died
uh at this point in time i can't confirm
a death but but just can i say that with
even with the see where i'm going with
it i i absolutely do and and the key
point is that you first of all if you
remember with uh when covid first came
to our shores
it arrived in january of 2020 we didn't
have our first death since until march i
believe and the reason is because there
is always a lag between infection and
then hospitalization and then sadly
death there's always a lag and that's
what we're even in so in south africa
where this uh this variant started
earlier yeah there's been a huge number
of hospitalizations they've been
doubling that's leveled off already
though hasn't it and fewer people are
now uh finding themselves on ventilators
in south africa and even the prime
minister or the president who's sadly
been confirmed with omicron um he only
has mild symptoms well there's a lot of
talk about you this might have it might
be less severe so milder the truth is no
one knows for sure at this point it's
very difficult to compare what's
happening in south africa to what might
happen here for example differences in
the age of the population the different
levels and types of immunity people have
you know how they gain that immunity but
it might well let's we can't rule it out
it might be more milder than the delta
but what the the difference that it
there exists is that the growth rate is
what's different and so if it grows at
such a phenomenal rate with
with a million with let's say a million
infections at the current growth rate by
the end of this month even when a virus
is mild a a small percentage of people
from a very large number still can equal
a high number of hospitalizations 75 000
deaths by may is what the london school
of hygiene and tropical medicine is
modeling um they have previously done
modeling um they uh forecasted in april
that uh we would suffer post lockdown uh
predicted 75 a 750 to a thousand deaths
a day by the end of summer 2021
that actually uh
resulted in something like 71 deaths a
day so how seriously can we take their
figures
well look those are their figures and
they they were modeling no it's not not
at all not all that that's their figures
they don't work for the government
they're an independent group
we will get our own uh advice from the
government's own scientists and we
listen carefully to that advice and at
the end of the day as ministers you have
to take all this into account and
understand the the trade-offs because
when you do take action like you know
we've asked people to work from home
from today you know this has a big
impact on people's lives it's a it's a
it's a it's it's not just a distraction
it can be really difficult for people to
to be away from the office not to have
that social interaction it can impact
their life chances so we we wouldn't
take this action lightly at all so based
on the advice that we're getting but now
also on the observed data we do have two
weeks of data where we are seeing this
phenomenal growth in infections it's
already we estimate it's around 40
percent of infections in london already
and and so because of this growth rate
and what we now know of the vaccines
that's why we've announced this national
mission on the booster program let me
put this to you if i may please health
secretary the prime minister said last
night he put the fear of god in us do
not make the mistake of thinking omicron
can't hurt you can't make you and your
loved ones seriously ill that's what the
prime minister said yesterday you're
telling me this morning we've only got a
handful of people in hospital with um
let me finish with omicron um as far as
you're aware probably none of them on
ventilators certainly nobody has died we
have been aware that this uh omicron
variant has been in the uk since october
so that gives us three months of data
and there have been no deaths
well as i say the the omicron has only
taken hold in the uk in the last three
weeks
it's already growing at a rate of
doubling two to three times uh two every
two to three days it's doubling
and we are at that rate you will have a
million infections by the end of the
month
and what that means is that even if the
severity so let's think of it this way
okay if i can explain it this way with
with with delta let's assume that of uh
all the infections around two percent of
those people end up in hospital with
omicron with omicron no no with omicron
let's assume it's half the severity it's
half the sphere that's just half it if
it's one percent of a much larger number
you still end up in a lot of
hospitalizations and and the the
what the government could do you know
there's there's a couple options here
for any government right well there
haven't been any deaths yet yes but
we've known about it being in the uk
since october well it's only
and there haven't been any deaths yet
what matters is when community
transmission starts and that's only been
actually probably
three weeks at most in terms of
community transmission that's what we
started to see in this country and
if the government just sort of stuck its
head in the sand and said let's just
wait and see what happens let's wait for
the deaths to happen by then it would be
too late the infections the growth rate
for the certain the next couple weeks
would have been baked in the doubling
times for the next three or four
doubling times would have been baked in
and then you'd have me here rightly
saying why didn't you act earlier why
didn't you actually have you not learned
any of the lessons about this virus have
you not learned about how to try to
protect people from it and to take
action in advance and you would have
rightly have been able to ask me those
questions okay but we've got to act
early and that's the reason to have this
booster program uh expand at the pace
that we wanted to see it and ask people
to please come forward and to protect
themselves it's the best way still to
protect us given that it's here are we
going to lift uh south africa off the
red list
we'll keep that under review but as as
as it spreads across the country there's
obviously less and less reason to put
any country on a red list because of
omicron but we are keeping an review
okay let me talk to you about downing
street um and uh what's going on there
if i may you were too upset to come in
last week weren't you i understand that
when you were looking at that video how
are you feeling about it now
well it's it's being investigated i'm
pleased that's being investigated
properly it's been properly looked at
labour demanding that the prime minister
answer questions in the commons not just
about that video but about a quiz that
he hosted
as well is that something that the
government should comply with well like
look i saw the photo of that quiz like
anyone else what what i can see is a
it's a virtual quiz with the prime
minister sitting at his desk but again
either prime minister
who was he talking to on the quiz i
think he's talking to some of his staff
on a virtual were they and where were
they all right
i don't know
it's not i don't it's duplicitous i
don't i don't know all the details what
i can what i can see the investigation
well i can see it's a virtual quiz and
and simon case has been given a broad
remit to investigate anything that he
thinks that
should be under
any type of gathering in downing street
that should be looked at on any
particular day he wants to and so if he
wants to look at this he will that's
going to be a decision for him it's not
right i think for a minister to tell him
what he should or should not investigate
he would have seen that photo i'm sure
himself but let him do his job and it's
right that it's a cabinet secretary that
does this that's a civil servant a
senior civil servant and that's the
right way to try and establish all the
facts but in order for that um to have
that investigation to have any
credibility it needs to report the start
of christmas doesn't it well i it
doesn't it's kicking the can down the
road well i think simon case will
determine for himself how long he needs
to to establish the facts and to look at
the evidence and i'm sure if he can
publish it sooner rather later he will
there's no reason not to
whatever the polling has uh is poor as a
direct result of what's been happening
with the with the prime minister um how
important is thursday's by-election to
the prime minister look every
by-election is important of course we
want to win it we're in there to fight
for every vote we're lucky we've got a
fantastic candidate neil shastri hearst
there's a he's worked to the nhs uh
he's uh he's worked in the in the in the
army and he's is a fantastic candidate
and i'm sure they anyone in shropshire
that meets him will like him but
ultimately uh it's about fighting for
every vote yeah the bookies and as my
dad always used to say i've never seen a
poor bookie um saying the lib dems are
going to win
well well let's let's see what actually
how will i have on the prime minister
and uh the respect that he has from the
party if he loses
any party wants to win any election
whether you're in government or not we
want to win this election we won one uh
just recently and we're going to work
hard and fight for every vote we're out
of time but let me just ask you whether
you saw lewis hamilton's race yesterday
i did not i didn't have the time i
didn't read about it i just didn't have
the time are you working on expanding
the booster program indeed are you an f1
fan uh i i'm not normally but i did
watch it last week and i really wanted
to watch it this time but you should
watch it back it's an absolute outrage
some might say not that i've got any
influence at all yeah but yeah i felt
sorry for him i'm a real fan of his and
uh and also by the way he's just done a
fantastic video with other formula one
players
encouraging everyone to come forward and
get vaccinated good to talk to you thank
you thank you dude i know you've got a
very busy schedule today thank you and
indeed
this side of the new year thank you